[Applause]
thank you very much we're hoping for a
good show tonight it was a tough tough
week for the line you know the line the
one that comedians sometimes cross that
tough week for the line got a lot of bit
a lot of work the line half the country
once Roseanne to go away forever half
the country wants cement the B to go
away forever so so much for wanting more
female voices in television Roseanne
will always be my friend but her world
came crashing down this week a series of
tweets she put out on Tuesday that were
just so full of racism conspiracy
theories and personal attacks they were
described as abhorrent bordering on
presidential
I think this is instructive and the
tweet that sealed the deal I think we
all saw it on television and I'm sure
when you first saw this you had the same
reaction I did I don't have a decoder
ring I have no [ __ ] clue what you
wing nuts in your bubble are talking
about now my friend Roseanne admitted
that she had been admitted to a mental
institution she has said she has
multiple personalities and unfortunately
one of them is quite a racist but it's
also not a mystery to me how a person
with mental illness could be taken in by
a party that has lost its mind
and the v-j in the tweet is Valerie
Jarrett who was one of President Obama's
key advisors and she took the high road
she said this is a teaching moment oh
what a day for Trump supporters huh
first they loose first they lose their
favorite show and they get threatened
with learning but you know Trump
responded in kind the way he always does
by focusing on the real victim him okay
this guy could tweet about the Hawaii
volcano would he'd make it about him I'm
orange and gassy
he was of course such a whiny little
[ __ ] he was complaining that ABC never
apologizes to him yeah because no one in
ABC ever compared you to an ape you're
thinking of me yes the snowflakes on the
right and yes there are plenty on the
right to try to drag me into this saying
I should be fired because I compared
Trump to an orangutan okay obviously
this is another day where we have to do
explaining jokes to idiots
[Applause]
here's why that's a dumb analogy it
overlooks four key facts one Trump is an
orangutan
two white people have not been subjected
to a racist trope comparing them to Apes
for hundreds of years my offering Trump
five million dollars to produce his
birth certificate in 2013 to prove that
he was not half an ape which I'm sure
you remember he then actually did sued
me went to court to get that five
million dollars
but I did that because it was self
itself a response to his birtherism
racist [ __ ]
so that's 3/4 I've already been fired by
ABC
now of course the other person who was
in hot water this week cement that be
apologized for her her joke which called
Ivanka Trump a feckless c-word and a
Trump was furious he said I am the only
one who gets to talk dirty about my
daughter
boy was he mad about that word not
confettis no idea what it means he was
like Ivanka buck is not loaded with feck
Ivanka love it maybe in the whole
history of the world nobody has more
effect than Ivanka
and I say that very strongly yes the man
who put grab them by the [ __ ] into
grade school history books is very upset
about the coarsening of the culture you
know Trump had much bigger things on his
mind this week he held historic talks
with Kim Kardashian
at the White House this really happened
is a picture of it you can find it
online if you google when America died
but but when you're thinking about it it
was probably a good meeting they have a
lot in common they both come from
reality TV they both have their own
brands they both screwed a lot of black
people it's
[Applause]
there actually was a high-level talk
today kim youngchul who is the north
north korean spy master he was in
Washington and delivered a letter to
President Trump trying to get the Korean
thing going again Trump says first of
the reporters it's an amazing letter
you'd pay me to see what was in it nine
minutes later he said I have not read
the letter really
is he a rose and Trump Redmon crazies
crazy but apparently the letter was very
polite but but direct it said if you
ever want to see Melania again place
fifty thousand dollars in small bills by
the base of the Washington London yeah
no one has seen the first lady in 22
days Wow
I she'll turn up and aren't we all gonna
get a good laugh and it turns out she
ran off with the Mexican gardener